au lycée agricole de challuy une
cinquantaine d'étudiants se forment aux
métiers de l'eau une filière qui a la
cote
car pour beaucoup l'intérêt vient avant
tout des questions d'écologie c'est déjà
une question un enjeu mondial et il faut
que chacun mettre son petit coup de
pouce pour comment s'en sortent tous
parce que malheureusement l'on en a
besoin
l'établissement propose un bts et une
licence professionnelle
deux formations qui ouvrent vers un
grand nombre de métiers vous pouvez très
bien réaliser des forages vous occuper
d'un réseau d'eau potable au sein d'une
commune gérer les milieux humides dans
une autre commune ou en montagne
et effectivement c'est cette diversité
qui fait l'intérêt de la formation car
les prévisions de raréfaction de la
ressource sont aussi inquiétante que
porteuse d'emplois pour la filière des
débouchés y en a les débouchés en
phrases des débouchés à l'étranger parce
que le sujet de l'eau sera d'autant plus
important à l'étranger avec des pénuries
de certains pays importante pour
certains étudiants les premiers contacts
noués ici leur permettront d'espérer un
emploi dès la fin de leur formation
d'autres approfondiront leur vocation en
master ou en école d'ingénieur mais tous
ont l'intention d'agir à leur échelle
pour l'environnement